[Music]
in the 4-hour workweek find out how you
can work a lot less and enjoy life more
author Timothy Ferriss explains how to
escape the 9 to 5 grind and work just
four hours a week life doesn't have to
be shown part it really doesn't now if
you told me that three years ago I
wouldn't have believed you but most
people went past self included have
resigned themselves to 9 to 5 grind in
exchange for sometimes although
increasingly less and less relaxing
weekends and the occasional one week
certainly no more than two week vacation
I came to realize that income really has
no practical value without time here are
a few simple steps you can take to
escape the rat race entirely not just
win it one of the first steps is the
process of elimination so to start you
need to consider something called
Pareto's long more commonly known as the
80/20 principle because in order to work
less not have everything fall apart
you'll have to quantify the 20% of
activities that are producing 80% of
your desired outcomes also take that
time to determine that 20% of activities
and people who are consuming 80 percent
of your time use this principle for
everything customers work tasks but also
for personal chores even for friends the
goal here is twofold number one to find
your inefficiencies in order to
eliminate them and then secondly this is
just as important to find your strengths
and those critical few tasks so you can
multiply your output
working every hour every minute from
9:00 to 5:00 with some type of digit
isn't the goal it's simply the structure
most people use it's actually a legacy
from a time that's already been
obsolesce in a knowledge economy the
more important thing is to shift from
presence to performance cut out static
all the things that consume time and
income out contributing back and focus
on the critical fuel you'll find that
very few things matter another critical
step and a real complement to
elimination is what I call the low
information diet or cultivating
selective ignorance keeping abreast of
all the new developments in any field
will consume all of your time it'll be
all input and no output you can't
possibly digest all that information so
a more effective approach is to try to
catch up when need be as opposed to
keeping up at all times a big part of
selective ignorance is learning to let
things wait for example email so email
is the single largest acceptable
interruption in modern life and it's a
very convenient way of simulating
forward motion without accomplishing
anything it shouldn't be a workspace
it's a tool and one of the easiest
methods I've seen for controlling email
and one that's become quite popular in
Silicon Valley is setting up a simple
autoresponder much like a vacation
auto-response
it says something like the following
dear all in an effort to actually get
work done I'm testing a new email policy
I'm checking and responding to email
only twice a day at 11 a.m. and 4 p.m.
Pacific Time or whatever your time zone
happens to be if you need a response
before one of these two times for
anything urgent please call me on my
cell phone thanks for understanding this
move to greater effectiveness and
efficiency whatever your name
this gives you the breathing room
finally two single tasks and focus on
completing the mission critical tasks
the critical few from start to finish
without interruption the third important
tool I'd like to mention and one of my
personal favorites is outsourcing life
to get started though we first need to
replace the very obsolete concept of
annual income there's a very deceptive
metric with hourly income and people are
generally extremely hesitant to delegate
or outsource because they feel they can
do something free themselves this is
very inaccurate so let's start with a
very basic calculation of hourly time if
you make let's say $50,000 per year cut
off the last three zeros I just fifty
and you divide that in half and you get
25 so you make $25 an hour this is
assuming you get two weeks off per year
and you're working forty hours per week
so let's just say on the very high end
that you can hire a personal assistant
at $30 per hour to handle one workday of
eight hours so your cost per hours and
five dollars so his or her 30 minus your
25 that means
$40 for full eight-hour day of freedom
so this also means that you can take a
three-day weekend every weekend will
cost you $40 per week I hire virtual
assistants around the world which only
takes a few hours help me with just
about everything from business research
to reading email cutting hundreds of
email down to four or five that I
actually have to deal with to travel
product development purchasing planning
parties even online dating there are a
lot of unorthodox and creative uses
personal outsourcing is only limited by
your imagination and the return on
investment is astounding four hundred
five hundred percent even for someone
who makes thirty forty thousand dollars
a year it's smart to focus on getting
things done but it's only possible when
you actually set your not to do list so
once we remove the constant static and
the distraction and focus on the
critical few and they're really just
aren't that
so I hope you enjoyed the book and just
remember that outside of the law and
science all the rules we follow our
rules we set ourselves so set yourself
up to win and choose your own rules
[Music]